We are now going to derive
the work-energy principle.
We're going to do so by
using Newton's second law,
but we're not going to consider
it with respect to time
as what we've previously
done, but we're now
going to consider it
with respect to space.
So F equals ma, and
we're going to take
the x component of that.
And now, we're going
to integrate this.
So Fx dx prime, and it
runs from x prime equals
x initial to some final value.
And then over here, we're going
to pull the m out. m integral,
and it also goes from some
initial to some final value.
And we're going to have ax dx.
We have previously shown
that this integral here
is one-half v final squared
minus v initial squared.
And if we're going
to plug this in here,
we're going to get
that this expression is
one-half mv final squared
minus v initial squared.
And you should
recognize this term.
This is the change
in kinetic energy.
And what we have here,
on the other side,
this integral fx
dx is defined to be
the work-- work done
on the system, which
we're going to call w.
And that work done
on the system,
it's change in kinetic energy.
So this is the
work-energy principle.